madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
inquiétudes en israël après la tentative
américano soviétique de relance de la
conférence de genève sur le proche
orient le dc-8 et japan airlines
détourné par des pirates de l'air depuis
quatre jours a quitté il ya quelques
heures le bangladesh 36 otages
l'équipage et onze pirates se trouvent
toujours à bord fin du voyage de
monsieur raymond barre en urss de près
ministre rentre ce soir à paris le
dixième anniversaire de la télévision en
couleurs en france voilà les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche 2 octobre des
titres relégué toutefois ce soir au
second plan par de nombreux français
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y avait l'arc et
piggott pour ceux qui sont moins
familiers avec les langages des
turfistes
cela signifie qu à longchamp cet
après-midi secours est le prix de l'arc
de triomphe et que cette course a été
remportée par le crack jockey anglais
leicester pig cela s'est passé devant
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens
des milliers et des milliers parmi
lesquels le président de la république
ont manifesté l'intérêt qu'il porte aux
courses et à l'élevage le président de
la république monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing avait tenu à assister au prix
l'arc de triomphe cet après midi à
longchamp avant la course le président
s'était rendu au rond de présentation
pour admirer les 26 pur sang quelle s
affronter sur les 2400 mètres de la
grande piste
les concurrents avant la descente en
tête le long de la corde a les gènes le
vin derrière lui tout près cros crystal
palace casaque bleue toque jaune et
orange mais pas de changement pour
aborder le dernier tournant toujours
alléger d'antenne lester piggott son jeu
qu'elle économise au maximum en
imprimant à cette épreuve à montreux à
500 mètres de l'arrivée
allais-je est bien calé le long de la
corde démarre trop le suis
orange mais craque complètement balle
mairie naulleau 2 commence à se
rapprocher
crystal palace n'est pas battu le sprint
est réellement lancée l'importante
colonie anglaise on court à son favori
devant leicester guen leicester
sur les onglets déchaîné allégée de ce
détail et riom avec beaucoup de facilité
il permettra aux paradoxes à piggott de
remporter sa première victoire en france
cette saison
mad mairie non le néo zélandais
terminera deuxième après une bonne fin
de course et crystal palace troisième
l'autre verser le vin le 2 le 10 nov
après la course que sur cinq stères
heureux propriétaires dans les gènes
en ce 20 des mains de madame giscard
d'estaing qu'une magnifique le jockey
anglais lester piggott était présenté à
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing le
félicitaient dans sa magnifique victoire
israël se tait et attend les pays arabes
sont ce soir satisfaits la déclaration
commune américano soviétique sur le
proche-orient diffusé cette nuit n'a pas
rapprocher les positions il est vrai
qu'il n'ya pas de miracle en politique
cet accord entre washington et moscou a
cependant fait ressortir une évidence
moscou comme washington veut régler le
problème des palestiniens pour éviter
une escalade de la violence
et peut être aussi la guerre au proche
orient en fait ce qui est le plus
surpris les israéliens c'est le
revirement de la position américaine et
le conseil des ministres qui s'est réuni
ce matin jérusalem n'a pu que constater
la gravité de la situation
moscou et washington demande à israël de
reconnaître les droits légitimes du
peuple palestinien et sa participation à
la conférence de genève
c'est la première fois que les états
unis prennent une telle position dans un
document officiel
pourquoi d'abord parce que le président
carter est décidé à régler une bonne
fois pour toutes ce problème du proche
orient dans lequel il voit une menace
très sérieuse pour la paix dans le monde
ce problème pense washington ne peut pas
se régler
tant qu'il existera une question
palestinienne c'est la première raison
du revirement amérique
la deuxième explication elle vient
paradoxalement israël par la voix digue
à la donne l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères condamne bien sûr la
déclaration américano soviétique mais la
justifier en partie par la politique
suivie par monsieur bédié depuis son
accession au pouvoir l'actuel
gouvernement il dit a réussi à détruire
en trois mois tous les efforts accomplis
pendant dix ans par les gouvernements
travaillistes pour éviter une telle
situation
derrière ces déclarations il y assure
tout
attitude du premier ministre israélien
face aux colonies de peuplement en
cisjordanie
ici à qaddoum à quelques kilomètres de
la pelouse mais la crème béguines les a
encouragés espérant créer un état de
fait qui lui permet de ne plus rendre
ces territoires occupés après la guerre
des six jours
les etats-unis n'ont pas du tout
apprécié cette attitude c'est sans doute
la dernière raison de leur viande
monsieur raymond barre sera de retour en
france dans un peu moins d'une heure et
demie le chef du gouvernement français
est en urss depuis mercredi ses
conversations politiques avec les
dirigeants soviétiques se sont achevées
vendredi soir depuis monsieur raymond
barre a fait un peu de tourisme à
leningrad soirée à l'opéra hier soir
visite de plusieurs musées l'occasion
pour le premier ministre d'oublier un
peu la politique tous ceux qui en lui
d'un seuil asti savent que leningrad ex
saint pétersbourg est une des villes les
plus humides du monde le ciel
aujourd'hui s'était mis à l'unisson des
fameux jet d'eau du palais de pétrole
vaut riasq visite monsieur bart
néanmoins et montbard a le sourire parce
qu'il estime que ces quatre jours passés
en urss ont été fructueux le commerce
franco soviétique était plutôt maussade
pendant les premiers mois de 2009 177
semble se débloquer pour la fin de
l'année mais plus que ses perspectives
immédiates
ce sont les perspectives à long terme
qui intéresse ruche bars et les
soviétiques aussi d'ailleurs
alors dans ce domaine le ciel est plus
bleu que celui qui nous couvre en ce
moment et il n'est pas exclu que dans le
début des années 80 les échanges
commerciaux franco soviétique qui
représente pour l'instant tout au plus 3
ou 4 % de notre commerce extérieur
arrive un pourcentage beaucoup plus
significatif par exemple 9 ou 10 pour ça
il ya un autre chapitre important c'est
le chapitre atomique il y a des années
déjà que les spécialistes de l'atome
français et soviétiques et chorges leurs
connaissances et aussi même leur
matériel on va continuer on va continuer
ferme pendant les années qui viennent
dans tous les domaines y compris dans
celui des sujets d sur régénérateur lui
a bien sûr quelques points un peu
douteux on ne sait toujours pas par
exemple quand l'airbus se posera à
moscou néanmoins je répète monsieur bart
avait le sourire en méditant leningrad
aujourd'hui on a vu le premier ministre
français sur le croiseur aurore le
fameux croiseur aurore du parti il ya 60
ans le coup de canon qui je tabac le
gouvernement provisoire et millet
au couloir puis raymond barre
accompagnés par les autorités locales a
parcouru les environs de la ville
après la russie révolutionnaire c'était
la russie impériale dont l'union
soviétique conserver le vestige avec un
soin jaloux par exemple ce palais de
verre pétrole mauriès le versailles de
pierre legrand était pratiquement
détruit il ya une trentaine d'années
après la guerre et le siège de leningrad
année après année on l'a resterai
jusqu'à lui rendre sa splendeur première
bel exemple de continuité russe qu'a pu
méditer raymond barre au terme de ses
entretiens politiques avec lui ni de
brejnev le dc 10 de la compagnie japan
airlines détourné il y a quatre jours
par un commando de l'armée rouge
japonaise a quitté la piste de dhaka au
bangladesh peu après 17h à son bord se
trouvait l'équipage quatre personnes et
29 passagers selon les derniers chiffres
le commando terroriste qui est lui aussi
bien sûr rester à bord se composait
finalement de onze personnes
tout au long de cette journée les
négociations se sont poursuivies sur
l'aéroport de dacca les autorités du
bangladesh voulait obtenir la libération
du maximum de d'otages
finalement dans l'après midi quarante et
une personnes ont été libérées par les
pirates de l'air maintenant une question
se pose où va aller ce décès 8 qui vient
donc de décoller de l'aéroport de dakar
on parle de koweit mais finalement on ne
sait pas très bien car les autorités de
coët les autorités de l'émirat viennent
d'annoncer qu'ils refuseraient tout
atterrissage de l'avion japonais sur le
territoire du koweit
alors peut-être sur un autre dans un
autre pays peut-être au proche orient
dans cette région si c'est à dire
peut-être en libye nous le serons
vraisemblablement vers 23 heures on sait
pas très bien à quoi cela est dû mais le
fait est là les sondages fleurissent
dans la presse hebdomadaire française
hier je vous parlais d'un sondage publié
par l'express aujourd'hui le point et la
vie française publie aussi des résultats
d' enquêtes d'opinion dans le point qui
est publié en première page avec un
dessin du peintre moretti l'ifop tente
de clarifier le débat sur les salaires
il s'agit là des salaires vu par les
cadres 80 pour cent des cadres
interrogés se déclarent très bien ou
assez bien payé ce même échantillon le
cadre estime aussi que l'éventail des
salaires devrait être de 1 à 7 entre
ans comme base un salaire de 1800 dans
la vie française c'est le crp le crêpes
qui a interrogé les jeunes de 18 à 30
ans sur le problème de l'argent
87 % des jeunes travaillent pour gagner
leur vie ce qui semble tout à fait
logique mais l'intérêt du travail bien
avant le salaire pour 69% des personnes
interrogées lorsqu'il s'agit de parler
des facteurs qui dans leur emploi sont
particulièrement satisfaisant en
revanche si cette question est posée à
des jeunes en chômage
le salaire vient alors et c'est là aussi
bien compréhensible bien avant l'intérêt
du travail dans le domaine politique
deux informations à noter rapidement ce
soir monsieur didier mau stan l'un des
créateurs du crs l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste demande la réunion d'un
congrès extraordinaire du ps pour
monsieur mouche thann
il s'agit de faire sortir de ce congrès
un certain nombre de propositions
destinées à sortir la gauche de
l'impasse et puis une autre déclaration
celle de monsieur jean luck annuel il ya
quelques minutes lors du club de la
presse sur un numéro un pour monsieur
lecanu est la rupture au sein de la
gauche est irréversible et il faut
désormais que par une politique
d'ouverture
la france politique se rééquilibre les
entretiens de bichat sont pratiquement
terminées les milliers de médecins qui y
ont participé vont maintenant rejoindre
qui leur cabinet qui leur clientèle
antenne 2 avec martin à la réunion a
fait pratiquement le tour de tout ce qui
s'est dit cette semaine à bichat entre
les spécialistes de la santé il nous
reste toutefois deux sujets à évoquer
dans notre dernière édition peu après
23h vous nous parlerait de la ménopause
mais tout de suite vous avez choisi de
faire le point ce soir sur les ulcères
et martin alarie news je crois qu à
bichât vous avez africain nouveaux
traitements existants de l'estomac et du
duodénum en oublie trop souvent mais il
n'ya pas que l'estomac alors vous savez
empoisonne la vie de très nombreux
français des sécrétions gastriques en
excès abîme la muqueuse de l'estomac ou
du duodénum
et à ce moment là vous avez la paroisse
qui rongeait et vous pouvez
vraiment avoir premièrement très mal et
deuxièmement une perforation restera
alors de nouveaux traitements existent
ils ne donnent pas tout à fait
satisfaction on prend état de
médicaments dits à 6 etc
mais cette fois-ci il semble qu'il y ait
un progrès de la biologie moléculaire
en fait les sécrétions acides sont
stimulés par une substance qui circulent
normalement chez nous qu'ils appellent
liste à 1000 et quand elle est en excès
il ya un excès de stimulation alors les
pharmacologues ont trouvé une molécule
qui ressemble à liszt aminés qui n'est
pas l'histamine et qui trompe les
récepteurs de la muqueuse je ne sais pas
si je me fais bien comprendre sélection
de la caisse et vous prenez une craie
qui n'est pas la bonne clé mais qui est
assez proche de la vraie clé pour aller
dans la serrure mais pas assez pour
pouvoir tourner alors ils ont pris deux
molécules qui ressemble la liste a une
qui ne l'est pas qui bloque les
récepteurs il n'y a plus de stimulation
donc plus sécrétion acide dans l'excès
dans ce football des vidéos hulu alors
ce traitement a l'air très efficace 900
cc oui alors nos centres hospitaliers
l'ont essayée sur 200 patients certains
témoins il on leur avait donné du talc
ou du sud et les autres on leur avait
donné cette molécule et il semble que
dans les deux tiers des cas c'est donné
d'excellents résultats
gérard martinez que cela veut dire que
désormais les ulcères à l'estomac
n'auront plus jamais avoir quelque chose
avec les chirurgies je crois que c'est
trop tôt pour le dire car on en est
encore à 200 cas pour l'instant mais en
tout cas les médecins les
gastroentérologues présents qui
représentaient vraiment un le sommet de
la gastroentérologie française semblait
très très encourageant bien martin on
vous retrouve tout à l'heure donc pour
parler de la ménopause peu après 23h le
raisin a fait son apparition depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà sur les étals
des marchands pourtant la grande saison
des vendanges n'a pas encore commencé en
ce domaine
et bien comme dans la beauce si je puis
dire pour le blé la mécanisation fait
également son apparition bientôt le
sécateur sera à ranger au magasin des
accessoires la tradition va y perdre ce
que le rendement yg à niort
dans certaines régions les vendanges non
plus le cacher folkloriques et
traditionnelles qu'elle avait voici
encore quelques années on fait de plus
en plus appel à une main d'oeuvre
étrangère payés au rendement est bien
souvent il ne s'agit plus d'une partie
de plaisir pour les viticulteurs et pour
les vendangeurs
mais à plus ou moins long terme les
vendanges manuelles vont être remises en
question car ici aussi la machine
remplace l'homme depuis quelques années
de grosses machines venues des
etats-unis ont fait leur apparition en
france et récolter les raisins aussi
bien sinon mieux que les vendangeurs
d'un prix très élevé elle va être en
moyenne 280 mille francs peu nombreux
sont les viticulteurs qui peuvent se
permettre de les acheter
quant au vieux vigneron s'ils sont
obligés de suivre le progrès ils ne
cachent pas leur nostalgie
maintenant on le fait ou bien vous
faites à sédières n'est pas bien du mal
vous faites plus vite vous tombez des
raisins par terre je voulais amasser
vous ramasser ça la passion et la
machine elle fait un meilleur travail
thym et la machine automatique au
maillot première puisque ce qui tombe
sûrement c'est minime au pistolet ou
douai le marché des machines à vendanger
risque très rapidement d'être mise en
question
en effet cette année sous l'instigation
de l' agence nationale de valorisation
et de recherche une petite vendange aux
aînés
la mini b coûtant moitié moins chère que
ses concurrentes
elle a surtout l'avantagé d'avoir un
rendement aussi important suivant la
longueur des parcelles l'ami nivea sur
la vendange de trois à quatre hectares
par jour alors qu'il faudrait au moins
trente à quarante vendangeurs offert le
même travail
d'après son inventeur lui même
viticulteur la mini b est une machine de
deuxième génération
j'ai voulu concevoir une machine
beaucoup plus adaptée d'une part au
vignoble français votre part une machine
beaucoup plus facilement accessibles et
utilisables par la majorité des
viticulteurs français
est-ce que vous pensez que précisément
dans toutes les régions on pourra
utiliser cette machine les modes de
conduite
sont très différents dans différentes
régions de france il est certain que ce
type de machine et celui qui s'adapte
semble-t-il le mieux aux différents
modes de culture qui lie actuellement en
particulier dans les régions
méridionales
et quand verra-t-on ce genre de machine
en le vignoble champenois par exemple en
suis conscient le vignoble champenois
je ne pense pas que ce soit pour tout de
suite mais il est certain qu'un jour et
certainement l'avoir mécanique se fera
en champagne d'après les études faites
la rentabilité de la mini b serait
assurée sur un vignoble de 15 à 20 ha
fini alors le problème posé par l'
embauche d'une main d'oeuvre temporaire
mais fini aussi le folklore et les
traditions des vendanges manuelles et
oui les vendanges mécaniques ce sera
peut-être encore un peu plus de bruit
dans nos campagnes homos le confort de
la vie devient l'une des revendications
essentielles des sociétés qui sont
développées industriellement
mais ce problème nous ne sommes pas les
seuls connaître on peut même dire que
les états unis nous ont précédés ils
l'ont découvert comme beaucoup d'autres
choses avant nous aussi à dix mille
kilomètres de chez nous sur les bords de
l'océan pacifique à quelques kilomètres
de san francisco un nouvel urbanisme est
en train de naître un urbanisme qui je
vous le précise n'est cependant pas la
portée de tout le monde à la portée de
toutes les bourses
si ranch sur les rivages du pacifique à
200 km au nord de san francisco les
berges elle vivait ici il ya quelques
années se loge en eux et leurs troupeaux
dans des cabanes en bois usé par le
temps un groupe d'architectes a eu
l'idée de préserver le site est de
reconstruire ici un groupe de maisons
dont le style est inspiré par celui des
anciennes fermes californienne il faut
conserver notre mémoire des chars lourds
le maître à penser de cette expérience
il faut apprendre aux gens à mieux
connaître leur environnement leur maison
il ne faut pas qu'une maison soit un
champ clos où l'on s'enferme mais plutôt
le lieu qui correspondent exactement à
notre histoire à notre passé charles
moore qui croient que l'espace doit
jouer un rôle important dans les maisons
du futur ma philosophie
eh bien il faut savoir que les gens de
californie sont des gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs et n'ont pas de racines
profondes ici quand ils viennent ici
c'est pour s'installer retrouver en
quelque sorte une partie de leurs rêves
les idées de charlesbourg font peu à peu
leur chemin que ce soit à los angeles ou
à san francisco les habitants de san
francisco est un associé de charnot
s'inspire de nos constructions
vous voyez là bas sur le port près du
golden gate
eh bien c'était d'anciennes galeries
qu'on a restauré et qui ressemble à
celle de sierentz où l'on a construit en
fonction de l'océan et de la lumière
changer les habitudes
la chose paraît facile dans un cadre
aussi favorable
vivre dans des maisons dont toutes les
structures sont en bois car ce sont de
grands morceaux de bois qui font les
joints et les supports de chaque maison
mais en californie le prix du bois n'est
pas cher
toutefois au delà des rêves de bonheur
il ne semble pas que le style de maison
de cire en soit encore accessible à tous
les californiens 250 mille dollars pour
vivre à 6 ranch
quand on veut s'y installer le prix de
la minute de bonheur et bien élevé
e
c'est difficile de dire tout le monde
peut en juillet en profiter en sourire
de profiter de la côte mais pour vous
dire pas ici ça coûte peut-être un peu
plus que pourra pour un livre pas dans
ces maisons est ce que vous pensez que
tous les californiens pourrait vivre
dans ce genre de maison à tous les
californiens mais les idées qu'ils sont
utilisés ici il y a dix ans sont
maintenant élitiste sans aucun doute ces
maisons de 6 ranch
mais elle laisse imaginer ce que seront
les maisons de demain dans lesquels
l'énergie par exemple ne sera plus le
problème essentiel
les premières maisons solaires qui
permettent le chauffage de l'eau ont
ainsi fait leur apparition à 6 ranch
un site enchanteur une vie idyllique
voilà qui nous entraîne bien loin ce
soir des personnages et des lieux
choisis par didier decoin pour son
dernier ouvrage john l'enfer pour
connaître un peu mieux didier decoin
alain gillot-pétré s'est donc rendu à la
défense dans ce new york parisien où le
béton et les tours ont remplacé les
pavillons de banlieue et les petits
jardins
c'est un peu par hasard si le personnage
principal c'est appeler john l'enfer de
nombreuses et et c'est après que je me
suis aperçu qu'il signifiait quelque
chose parce que john l'enfer c'est un
indien cheyenne qui lavent les carreaux
des gratte-ciel de new york parce que
les indiens n'ont pas le vertige
oui le vertige à l'envers en regardant
en regardant cette ville immense debout
et qui est malade écrit malade au point
peut-être bientôt de s'effondrer et ce
qui est bouleversant c'est que new york
a fini pour moi en 1881 en étant 77 new
york n'a pas tout à fait sans tant à
l'échelle d'une ville c'est l'âge d'une
toute petite fille alors c'est la mort
d'une petite fille et la mort d'une
petite fille
moi ce que je trouve de plus
bouleversant à travers votre lit fait un
peu aussi la mort d'une civilisation
c'est la mort de toutes les
civilisations s'élabore des
civilisations qui ont mal compris le
problème est qu'ils ont construit comme
disait alphonse allais des villes à la
campagne et si vous voulez la
civilisation urbaine qui est la nôtre à
l'est comme à l'ouest d'ailleurs et je
le crains une civilisation en passe de
de mourir utilisation condamné pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas new york new york
était vraiment cette ville de crasse et
d'abandon vous décrivez de crasse oui
incontestablement il ya des tonnes et
des tonnes d'ordures qui restent dans
les rues tous les jours d'abandon
physique certainement et ce qui est peut
être pire aussi d'abandon moral
c'est une ville dont les êtres sont des
souvent des êtres perdus des êtres en et
adhérence ce sont des des zombies vous
savez et j'écris john l'enfer parce que
ce n'est pas un être humain qui meurt
c'est une chose c'est une
ville mais je crois que lorsque new york
ne sera plus que comme pompéi une plaine
de pierrailles de d'europe qu'on
visitera les new yorkais te continueront
de vivre peut-être à côté
peut-être plus loin ils ont reconstruit
leur univers il y deux points la plupart
de vos personnages sont des ratés des
déclassés des marginaux pourquoi je
crois que nous sommes tous des ratés des
déclassés des marginaux des classes et
marginaux sûrement dans un monde très
difficile raté aussi quand on pense
qu'un homme au bout de 90 en mettant les
choses au mieux et balayez de la surface
de la planète qu'il a essayé pendant
tout ce temps de construire quelque
chose et ce quelque chose aussi bien
finir pour beaucoup de gens c'est une
espèce de forme de ratages pas pour moi
mais pour beaucoup
quand on est écrivain et qu'on réussit
on est aussi un raté écrivain je le suis
réussi à vous savez ça veut dire faire
le livre comporte en soi exactement je
pense pas qu'il ya c'est l'écrivain
français ni même mondial qui aujourd'hui
vous dirait j'ai fait ne livre que je
rêvais de faire n'est toujours un ton en
dessous de son rêve de l'enfer donc le
dernier livre de didier decoin
en venant sur ce plateau de télévision
ce soir j'aurais pu apporter avec moi un
gâteau sur ce gâteau j'aurais pu placer
10 bougies et ensemble vous et moi ainsi
que tous les techniciens qui m'entourent
ce soir nous aurions pu souffler ses
bougies et oui il y a dix ans la
télévision en couleurs naissait en
france alors avec martine martin joubert
nessuno nous un peu de ses débuts
1er octobre 1967 le roi hussein se
rendant visite au caire on prépare pour
le salon de l'auto la nouvelle
alpine-renault les personnalités se
succèdent devant les urnes
ce sont les cantonales les grands titres
de la presse ce jour là et pourtant dix
ans après le véritable évènement du jour
celui qui a coloré la vie quotidienne de
nombreux français étaient annoncés par
la speakerine le 1er octobre les
programmes de la deuxième chaîne quitté
le noir et blanc sans se mettre en verre
et à deux heures de l'après-midi les
français assisté aux premiers directs en
couleurs un saut de parachutistes rouge
et blanc venus de quelques arc-en-ciel
ccam français pas l'allemand nts et
américains chaque grande nation défend
dé son propre aux procédés de télévision
couleur
la guerre de la couleur n'est toujours
pas terminée les un des pionniers de
l'époque se souvient surtout d'un grand
saut dans l'inconnu pour lui et son
équipe
disons beaucoup de solidarité et de
passion professionnelle
voilà ce que ça a coûté beaucoup de soin
il dira et beaucoup d'exigence
parce que là que le signal couleurs ce
n'est pas un c'est un signal tragique
dépassiez plus complexes et par
conséquent il ne tolère pas la
médiocrité
je pense que il serait bon que les
professionnels de 1977 reviennent un peu
et pense est toujours présent aux
exigences qui était celle des
professionnels de 67 pour avoir une
qualité qui soit toujours par 70
homogène alors que quelquefois ne l'est
pas
depuis 10 ans le prix de vente des
postes couleur n'a pas bougé entre 4000
et 5000 500 francs donc en tenant compte
de l'inflation
à post couleurs vaut moins cher
aujourd'hui hier les quatre millions de
propriétaires de poste de télévision en
fleurs peuvent enfin reconnaître les
verts des rouges
aujourd'hui ils savent qu léon zitrone a
les yeux clairs jean pierre elkabbach
l'oeil noir et les cheveux châtains
foncés et qu'en noir et blanc patrick
lecocq perd tout à fait son regard bleu
du bleu qui n'apparaitra pas tellement
demain matin dans le ciel de france il
pleuvra du bassin aquitain aux alpes et
au sud de la france dans l'après midi
temps variable avec alternance
d'éclaircies et de passages nuageux
les averses se localiseront sur le nord
le nord-est et l'est voilà vous
connaissez maintenant à 20h26 les
principales informations de cette
journée notre prochain journal aura lieu
aux alentours de 23h30 et 23h20 3h30
j'aurai le plaisir alors de vous
retrouver
bonsoir